bracing for impacts in a Peking
coronavirus cases expected next month
Florida is preparing for what could be a
brutal onslaught almost a quarter of
this state's population is over the age
of 60
placing millions of its residents in the
high-risk category many of Florida's
iconic destinations are now deserted but
the statewide order to stay at home came
long after other states already enacted
similar measures during the almost
two-week debate on whether to issue the
order the number of coronavirus cases
here rocketed on April the first one
month after the state's first confirmed
case the order finally came given the
the unique situation in Florida I'm
gonna be doing an executive order today
directing all Floridians to limit
movements and personal interactions
outside the home critics of DeSantis who
was initially worried about the impact
on the economy say it's too little too
late supporters of the Republican
governor say was a measured step by step
approach on March the 23rd governor
DeSantis rejected the idea of a lock
down by the time he gave the order at
the beginning of April the number of
cases here had increased fivefold that
delicate balancing act between saving
jobs and saving lives is won many
governors are now facing whether the
delay here led to the loss of life is a
debate for the future and a highly
politicized one it's also a stark
example of the life and death decisions
leaders are now having to make
dissenters has been criticized for
excluding religious gatherings from his
order Tampa mega church pastor rodney
howard-browne was arrested over defying
public health orders the arrest warrant
being signed by De Santis critic Andrew
Warren well social distancing is the
only error we have in our quiver it's
the one thing we can do right now to
actually flatten the curve and we know
that it works we want to do it in a
responsible but aggressive and effective
way and so the mixed signal signals were
getting out of Tallahassee undermines
that process health experts say
hospitals in Florida will be strained by
the summer as the death toll rises but
politics should be put aside for now we
will come out of this but we need to
come as a nation need to come together
and forget our bullet
call de France right now and focus on
treating patient and be ready for the
second wave and be ready for a good
recovery and faster come Florida faces
some unique issues as cruise ships with
sick passengers dock crops rot in the
field and unemployment lines grow but a
focus now is on saving lives and a
Gallacher al Jazeera Miami Florida